an amazing lineup of CEOs Founders and
experts this is marketing for the now
[Music]
how are you good the office is rocking
today
we are starting to get back at
vaynerxland we've been pretty remote all
year with a little bit of optional but
next year we're coming back stronger
with what I think is going to be a
really fun schedule for everyone you
know not five mandatory days but two uh
with a mix and I think we're gonna test
it and I'm excited that's right but I'm
also excited about to say hello to Alex
Ray and Palmer a and Janine Kelly on uh
LinkedIn Jamie Lee hiscox in South Wales
UK on Facebook uh Hugh who works at
Vayner
and here on YouTube
you know TV 3.0 genius Karina B on
Facebook uh just great to see everybody
Vicki J uh who's saying happy birthday
Nick Dio I mean Vicki J is on top
so anyway glad to be here
yeah I know we're super fired up to have
everybody joining us the last episode of
this year I can't believe it the sun is
shining outside but it is cold and icy
but we're gonna heat it up we're gonna
talk a little bit about
um the look back on 2022 as we're
gearing up for 2023. uh and we decided
to bring a bunch of our friends and
family our clients and some partners and
things like that to talk about what
they've learned so they can throw down
some insights so super excited to have
to bring up Tim Armstrong first
so he is from Disney to Google to AOL to
Verizon and now he's the CEO and founder
of floco and he's going to tell you all
about what he's up to so nice to have
you Tim good to see you both I saw you a
lot this year so awesome to spend time
and Gary it's great to see you brother
good day
how are you doing well how are you doing
give me give me your uh one through ten
on how you're feeling by the end of the
year 10 10 being awesome how you feeling
um I would say a seven and only reason
it's not eight nine and ten is because
the Jets have lost to the Vikings and
the bills and back-to-back weeks and I'm
really sad about football right now but
otherwise actually a 10 10 for 10 for
real life negative three for a current
state of football feeling though at 10
overall because it's finally a good
season all right let's not take up too
much time you're one of the true iconic
businessmen of the last 20 years in my
opinion being at the helm of a lot of
digital leaders ship roles and some of
the biggest companies I'm actually
smiling when you were getting introde
because your backdrop looks like you're
still onto campus at Google or somewhere
right now I don't know where you are but
it's making me smile really beautiful
Stanford Connecticut I'm at the flow
code off site at the end well thank you
for doing this I'm going to let you you
know we've started a little late and
you've got the off-site so we're not
going to hold you you know given that
you've sat at the helm of AOL we're a
super top executive at Google you've
been through this journey of web one web
two and now going into web three you
know I really have always felt that you
have been a unique guy that I've always
admired uh not only because you've been
at the Forefront and been very capable
but also I think you're very light well
liked by the people that actually
interact with you and so you live the
kind Warrior you know honey Empire stuff
that I care about so I want to give you
those roses and I want everybody to know
that truth so I think your perspectives
are going to be powerful so I'm going to
let you rant here what you know when you
think back on looking back at 2022 from
a business lens but feel free to add to
that what what's your take
you know Gary three things one is I
think we moved from the pandemic to the
team demick one of the things we say a
flow code is the product is the team and
the team is the product so right now
we're a company we we're basically have
no rules on whether we're hybrid or in
the office but because we focus so much
on trying to build a great team to build
a great product I I've noticed like
people are our team is probably 50 to 70
percent back in the office
um now and I think just that simple
focus on moving to a team democ where we
focus in on team has been been huge
that's the second thing I think is um
you know you and I have lived through
these Cycles before and we've been in
the business for about the same amount
of time is I think 2022 will go down as
one of the best years to actually invest
in things even though it looked like the
world blew up I think this reminds me a
lot of the.com bubble in the financial
crisis which is everybody who ran away
this year will be outstripped by the
people who decide to stick with it and
stay involved and I think like I'm super
excited about web 3 I think like the
decentralization of data and dollars is
going to be like this year will probably
end up looking back looks like there's a
lot of issues right now but it's
probably the biggest year for the
kickoff it's to your point because
you're really in it and I was I was in
Jersey but I was in it because I had
a.com in that era so I was paying
attention you know I mean look it's the
stuff that I was putting out all year 97
of this stuff was gold rush and that's
why it's getting beat up but no question
whether it's nfts or other blockchain
technology like the two three percent is
going to be the Amazon AOL paypals of
that era because they didn't die and
they were talented and they were good it
just hard you know for a lot of people
who are watching right now that are none
of T land and see their nfts down 80 90
they weren't there into they didn't own
pets.com stock that they paid 113 for
that was three cents totally so they
it's all new for a lot of people because
back then to buy stock in the late 90s
early 2000s you had to like kind of be
of a certain wealth you had to kind of
like know it here everybody learned and
was able to do it decentralized which
speaks to the capacity of the
opportunity totally
and Gary I think the other thing is like
at the World level right now that
there's trillions of dollars and
trillions of pieces of data that are
stuck on you know six or seven Platforms
in the world and I think that the what
you just talked about with nfts is you
can say you know whatever happened this
year with nfts and crypto and blockchain
and those things but the reality is that
force is too powerful to stop and I
think there's a Renaissance period that
the internet felt like the Renaissance I
think the real Renaissance is actually
starting you know now and I and the one
thing I think you've been really good at
Gary over the years is one of the books
I read this I read about 30 books this
year but the one that stands out
probably the most is a book by three
McKinsey Consultants that studied you
know how to success I studied 2600
companies and um out of the 2600 there
were basically 200 that hit all their
goals and 2400 that didn't and the main
characteristic difference between the
2400 and the 200 where how fast people
adapted resources and strategies and how
much they did the 2400 companies only
moved about one percent of their
resources into new areas when they came
up in the new the strategy of where the
world's going and the 200 companies that
were really successful moved between
like 10 and and 40 percent of their
resources so the last thing for this
year is like are you bold enough as a
leader to actually move to this a lot of
stuff that you've been doing and you've
done at vaynermedia and Vayner X you've
been doing it for years and gotten ahead
of the market but I think one of the
things I'm doing at flow code is you
know we have a very differentiated
offline strategy that helps people get
their first party data and first party
Commerce done is even in our company
we've been a little bit ahead of the
curve but can we Jam 35 percent of our
resources and time into the new areas of
the world and that's that's what I'm
spending this off-site at with our team
right now is is we have to be bold
enough to keep making bold decisions
because the market I think is going to
change dramatically in 2023.
I love it brother listen I wish we had
more time I adore you really quick I'm
going to sneak one more second the AI
chat the chat GPT hesitate your radar
yet the you know open AI like the this
chatbot is it feels for a lot of people
the first time they're really seeing AI
instead of the bubble gum and tape of
the hype any thoughts or have you not
had the time because you're so busy I
said there's a work there the biggest
change I've seen since the start of the
internet or the iPhone is I think this
is like the internet is a horse and chat
uh gbt is like going to
um a Tesla I mean I think it's the
largest single change that's gonna it's
the first thing that I've seen that I'm
like oh Google needs to pay attention to
this 100 first thing on a d platforming
yep love you brother we'll talk soon
thanks Tim all right next up we're going
to bring Olga Osman Kina Jones who's
from Wreck it
and Olga has a pretty exciting job she's
leading the reinvention of the future of
intimate Health sexual pleasure and
rights all Guided by consumer desires
and needs we're super excited to have
you Olga
yeah
consumer small audiences so how about
just people yes very real Olga you know
I've had the great Fortune of getting to
know you I consider your friend and I do
really think that you have one of the
things that con you know listen I've met
thousands of people in marketing in the
last 13 years one of the reasons I
continue to lean in to our relationship
is I feel like you have really good
consumer instincts which you know very
honestly
the world that I live in where Tim lives
that's more common because other
startups that really in corporate world
it's a little more rare because it
becomes a little more Corporation but I
I think you know the work that you've
done at PepsiCo and now record like it's
just very obvious to me that you get it
so from a consumer standpoint from a
human standpoint to your point
um what were the big changes in 2022
that really caught your attention what
was an aha what was an affirmation what
stands out when you think back at uh
2022
oh first of all Gary thank you for for
recognizing what I really cherish as I
think it is my superpower to stay close
to people uh in the end we serve them
that's why we are here right
um look I think there was a lot of aha
moments
um I think reconciling technology and
just the role of human factor technology
kept us together but put us at a
distance in covet and I think um you
know Tim talked about it as well but
that notion of
human touch whether it is staying close
to people with Servo just bringing
people we work with together remember
how wonderful it was for us to get back
into it yeah just brainstorm have fun
with it and open up
um the creativity the creative flow
impossible to do I think over over tap
love Tech does a lot for us but that
human factor being together was a real
aha moment you know there is a time and
place for everything
look in terms of how we connect with
people another big aha moment and that's
something we lived through together with
you and the whole vaynerx team and Durex
and particular brand team is how do we
stop just following platforms and kind
of jumping on the wagon of whatever it
is happening in the world and start
shaping uh how people connect with
Brands and instead of just you know
responding to whatever is going on in
the world actually shaping the behavior
through very relevant message not trying
to market the product but really shaping
the lifestyle and providing tools for
people to open up a conversation
what we've been doing with you on Tick
Tock for me is a big um showcase of that
I think we've learned a lot what is not
working but we equally celebrated a ton
of what is well I think you know what's
so fun about what's not working is uh
for everybody who's an entrepreneur or
startup in Big Brand land and Olga's
been a superstar in that world for the
last 60 years A lot of it is you make
decisions of smart people and research
in boardrooms and then you spend a lot
of money you know by our small business
and entrepreneur Realms on putting it
into the world and so there's a lot of
subconscious to the cost of a mistake
what Olga's referring to is for a lot of
people are listening both marketers at
the unfortune 500 but the startups is
the model of trying to win on relevance
and marketing every day as if the way
they used to by the way I've been doing
earlier like this I've been looking on a
case study that we're building a banner
of how Betty Crocker was built and a lot
of it was how we see the world they did
tons of print in different markets tons
of radio in different Market with
creative that was contextual to the
market then looked at the feedback loops
and I made decisions they didn't have
the internet so slower and different but
what's not working is a positive I put
out a piece of content social the other
day of how much I like when my content
falls on its face even though I thought
it was going to do well it's science the
learning
big brands are not accustomed to that
because even subconsciously it's like
the creative is expensive but in the
model the creative is not expensive by
comparison and there's a lot of learn
that what doesn't work helps you to find
what does work and that's a powerful
framework that hasn't been happening as
much in Fortune 500 land listen I
couldn't agree more and frankly I think
the trick is to get out of that space of
its ass versus them it's us and then
there are some consumers as if they're
aliens how about we just put ourselves
in the shoes of people we're trying to
serve and stop talking about masses stop
talking about groups that we don't get
but try to actually get them that the
skin of John or Gary or Olga out there
and frankly often it's that creating
that Groundswell right as you were
saying contextual relevant in the moment
often that approach touches enough of
Mass to create the Snowball Effect and
you know in my humble opinion often this
concept of connecting that mass is
misunderstood it's not about trying to
be everything to everyone it's just
really getting under the skin of people
who you need to love what Auditors
you're doing in the world and do it
right for them
I love that what else what else stood
out well we got a couple minutes
anything else actually real quick let me
just say hello real quick tat Keith L
Bennis good to see you vape Warrior
don't Vape it's not good for you Vicki J
12 Matt C LinkedIn
how you read all the names
people know where we're here with them
Ginger yeah
what else is a hot take of something
that caught your attention yeah
I think it will be very much uh in your
alley um I am watching what's gonna
happen with web 3 nfts this whole Space
because I think right now it's very easy
to chicken out then step back and act as
if this has never happened and the
reality is you know anything new always
has ups and downs and it's a question of
how we weather the storm and continue to
experiment but not experiment for the
sake of Technology again understand the
value the utility that we can create for
the people we serve and use it use the
tools whether it's nft web 3 whatever it
is use the new tools to just enhance uh
people's experience
I think that's right I mean I remember
the internet search engines the Internet
stock prices even people forget but
iPhone apps there was tons of articles
uh there's always fun they're like oh
the apps are not doing as well the
Blackberry was more than fine like it's
just always this was so spectacular
because there was fraud there was there
was way too much hysteria you know
people heard what they wanted to every
day I was putting out 99 is going to
zero 97 has gone to zero people heard
what they wanted to it right yeah it
happens but nonetheless thank you happy
holidays adore you we'll talk soon I'll
see you soon talk soon ciao thanks Silka
all right next up we've got Jessica
Williams from coinbase
Jessica leads brand and marketing
Partnerships and experiential she's
calling in live from La
um she's focuses on all things web 3 at
coinbase and before she joined coinbase
two years ago she held a whole slew of
different roles at Visa thanks for
joining us Jess hey Gary
it's great to see you Jess how are
things yeah uh things are great I'm
actually in San Diego not La
um but you know same for so much yeah
for us East Coasters it's it's nice and
it's cold out here
too but yes you know you know look this
set up nicely both Tim and Olga touched
on this I think um you know you're
sitting front row one of the biggest
companies in the space you know
um what's the you know boy oh boy what
you know 2022 is going to be a year that
you speak to your great great grandkids
about in heaven about like you know that
was a wild professional year like UPS
the Downs the lefts then right so would
love to get a sense of where where you
take this yes absolutely also hard to
concentrate while the um the hearing is
going on with SDF but um is that
happening right now yeah
is going to be the year uh that we
um learned how to do smaller planning
Cycles uh so no longer do year-long
plans work uh you gotta plan in
quarterly Cycles monthly cycles and um
as Tim said be really flexible with your
resources and your budgets to shift
where it's most needed
um I think we saw that we had full plans
baked out in 2022 and each month each
quarter like those got blown up and we
had to start again and I think it builds
a real muscle with your teams internally
to be able to sort of reset and refocus
shift your resources not worry about
what you got hired to do or what you
were best at last year but then to
really go where the business is going
um and go where the business is needed
I love that
um I think on that same note uh we did
not plan for the worst uh in 2022 and at
Visa one of my bosses used to always
make us do pre-retros so what's the
worst thing that could happen uh within
this campaign launch product launch
um you name it and let's plan for that
and um I'm gonna make my teams do a bit
more of that in 2023 just what's the
worst thing that could happen here and
let's make sure we have a plan for that
as well I'm not sure we could have
predicted this but uh at least maybe we
would have been a little more
um a little more ready yep what um what
you you know a lot of people let's
really help people today a lot of people
here are destined to be at the helm of a
senior leader or someone negatively
affected by you know a hard correction
right you know 2029 we could go into a
very aggressive fast recession 2037 we
may have a world event that creates it
taking a more optimistic view what what
nice things come out of a reset that is
very painful you know uh
what what what do you think you've
learned I don't know if you and your
career have had a reset of this size you
and I have been in the workforce a
little bit longer than some of these 20
year olds so I don't know where you were
in your professional career I mean
2008's a little while ago now it is I
actually was working on Lehman uh when
they fell so no I go wear the chaos no
just you worked at Lehman when 2008 hit
I was working as a financial analyst on
a company that was doing work for Lumen
yes I see so you're affected by wow not
at Lehman but uh very similar like very
involved in the insurance
um I think for me and what I see is that
um there's gonna be a real opportunity
for smaller leaner teams less hierarchy
clearer alignment more tests and learns
less you know sort of polished
everything and I think this gives both
young and more Senior People time to
really grow and really
um dig in do more things uh be
responsible for
um more impact I think within every
business layoffs are never easy and I
would never wish that upon any company
or any person but I do think it provides
an opportunity for people to really
stretch both out and up and and it gives
more people more opportunity to launch
and grow and lean into places that they
may not have in the past and I think
that's a real opportunity for everyone
across all Industries
um not just big Tech
what um what else on the consumer lens
oh
all right what else on the consumer lens
are you seeing
um I think the big one that I have been
loving is well Andrea first of all
Andrea get her back on you even even if
it looks a little good and Dustin's good
that was so good you'd be in there that
fast I'm really impressed like you
really got my back thank you hey I love
Jess I love you so we're all hearing
this I also like clicking and doing nine
things at once up
um
let me finish this off because Andrew's
gonna take over here in a second what uh
what else do you see
on the consumer lens that really caught
your attention
um by the way it could be outside of web
3 it might be something your favorite
brand in cereal or handbags or like what
what was what else was interesting in
2022 I honestly just think this hundred
this thousand true fans
um mentality has grown so significantly
even for large Brands um I love the idea
that
um you know Nike is in I mean they're
still interested in the mass media but
that they are really speaking to there
are a thousand true fans through
dotswitch launch
um same thing with Starbucks like they
are obviously looking for everyone but
really focused on their true fans who
are going to launch with them on Odyssey
um I think we're gonna see more and more
of that where
um you don't necessarily need every
single person you really need those
people who are most vocal most
interested um and who are gonna do the
thing that you want them to do
um I also feel like decentralized
everything is exciting to me
um not the same sort of powers in the
hands of you know 10 or 20 big companies
but that we're seeing everyone
proliferate across so many different
mediums and Brands and access points
that we're going to see smaller
businesses really rise to the top
because they're going to be able to find
these niches
um where decentralization comes first
I love it I love it well listen one last
one last question for me personally
we've we've had a there's a lot of
people here who go to business events
do event marketing you and I have had
the luxury of like intersecting a little
bit on that
um and uh I'd love to get your
observations on that space the there's a
lot of B2B people that listen to this
and watch this what is the value of when
you look back in 2022 of in-person
events in the looming next decade of
metaverse like what do you think happens
there what's the good what what can be
better what are your thoughts
I think that
um we will continue to thrive on
in-person events I don't think there's
anything that
um comes over in real life relationships
that are built at events
um I do think we need to make them more
accessible to everyone so that it
doesn't only lay in the hands of the few
however what I've come to realize is
that you don't need the massive party or
the the biggest experiential what you
need to do is provide a good experience
with the right people in the room and
that is all that truly matters and so I
feel like a real focus on the quality
um of the people and the experience and
that doesn't have to be a full
experiential but it could just be a
really engaging brunch with a fun you
know like
um at Red Bull did at Art Basel where
you know they brought a bunch of
creators together and doodled on a car
it was fun it was engaging and it
brought the right people people in the
room to have a really meaningful
conversation that I think can never be
replaced and I encourage folks to create
those experiences where folks come and
they feel when they left that a large
impact on their future could be made
I love that
thank you happy holidays great spending
time with you this year looking forward
to more thanks very so much for having
me
thanks Jess and thank you Gary the end
of a year I can't believe it I'm gonna
go to my Discord right now garyvee.com
Discord come and hang there as you guys
continue it Andrew a great year of this
show you've got some killers on here so
keep it going that's right that's right
we're going to bring Avery acanini up
the president
of our web3 business vayner3 how's it
going Avery
doing really well thank you so much for
squeezing uh me on to the last episode
of marketing for the now for 2022. I'm
excited to be here well I'm missing you
I loved spending some time in art basil
Jess was just talking a little bit about
it it was quite quite the year
quite the quite the event that uh that
you led there
but let's uh we're gonna bring up Devin
negay who uh is is the director of tech
and emerging platforms at Diageo where
he's known for leading their North
American digital Innovation and
disruption I'm gonna kick it over to the
two of you
awesome thanks so much
and thank you for joining us Devin
um when we were deciding who would be
the perfect sort of cap off for 2022.
you were at the top of the list um
you've been such an amazing partner this
year and I feel like we've done a lot in
2022 Diageo and all the brands that you
sort of support and help oversee um have
done a lot in the world of web3 so we're
hoping to share a little bit with our
listeners on what you've learned this
year
yeah for sure and just to kind of
explain my role at the company really
quick just uh for those who don't know
Diageo we are a global leader in the
spirits business so we are a portfolio
of consumer Brands you might have heard
of Smirnoff Crown Royal Johnny Walker
bullet cost Amigos the list goes on
um these brands have been around for for
a long time so when it comes to digital
Innovation I focus on helping Our Brands
obviously stay relevant in culture uh
using technology to find new ways to
reach our consumers and to make sure
that we're keeping Our Brands relevant
right and so web3 is a huge uh piece of
culture right now it's really important
uh so we've we've spent a lot of time
this year getting Our Brands into this
space with the help of our friends at
banner3 and Avery and her team so uh
we've done a lot I'm happy to speak to a
couple examples if you'd like
um my my favorite example is a project
we recently worked on called web3. crown
royal.com
um uh this was a really fun project
where we we took an existing
purpose-driven marketing initiative and
we brought it into web three uh so what
the brand has done in the past is we've
uh packed the iconic Crown Royal purple
bag that you see here with characters
from with care items for service members
serving overseas and so with web3. crown
royal.com we we created a digital
collectible uh of a piece of beautiful
crown royal artwork minted uh created by
a web3 artist and for every Crown minted
we packed a purple bag we actually had
this call to action on screen on the
bills uh Lions NFL game on Thanksgiving
days it was a big moment for us uh and
we're really excited to have the brand
step into web 3 in this way and now we
have this engaged community of crown nft
holders that we we're going to nurture
and deliver exciting things to over the
course of the next couple months so
we're really excited about that but
generally obviously 2022 has been an
incredible year for us getting into web
3 in authentic ways and we're excited to
do more
I love that and that program was really
interesting because I think a lot of the
listeners here might be you know reading
certain things in mainstream media that
talk about speculative investing they
talk about what's happening with FTX
they talk about um you know some of that
that hype cycle and what you're talking
about with Crown Royal though is really
a campaign that uses um like web3 for
good that both builds a community for an
existing well-established brand while
actually going to serve up a sort of
purpose in supporting the generous
initiatives that Crown Royal is doing so
I love web3. crown royal.com and I
encourage people who are listening to
this to go check it out and for every uh
crown that is claimed uh the Diageo team
is going to send one of these purple
bags to active duty military which is
just such a nice story and it was cool
because you all are actually the second
brand to um launched on salesforce's nft
cloud which I think is also pretty
um Monumental like Salesforce being a
huge web 2 giant that really pioneered
digital CRM
um and Diageo being one of the first
Partners to kind of be in as part of
that pilot what was that experience like
yeah I mean that was a very eye-opening
moment for for us and our marketers at
Diageo I think one of the most
encouraging things that that I see
certainly in the web 3 space is the
amount of investment coming into the
space from existing large-scale players
in the cloud business Cloud technology
business like Salesforce so Avery's
right we did work with Salesforce uh
using their nft Cloud project to to get
this project into uh into the wild and
into culture we were excited to do that
and I think there's a lot of promise
that we can look to there as marketers
as we connect our existing kind of
marketing business processes and
practices to connect web3 with all of
those systems that are already in place
so Salesforce does a lot for us we also
worked with a partner called cross mint
on this specific Activision which really
helped us mint at scale right so another
encouraging sign for me is removing a
lot of that confusion and free action
associated with minting nfts storing
nfts and the value that they can deliver
so I think with Salesforce and cross
mint combined we were able to kind of
get to that seamless consumer experience
that we want to deliver through digital
uh at scale uh certainly for for Brands
like Crown Royal we have to be
activating at scale and that's what
we're going to look to do in the future
and you know this space is evolving so
quickly every week there's there's a new
development uh positive development
um you know to help consumers get on
board into web3 so I think we're we're
excited about that as well
awesome and Johnny Walker was I believe
the first uh diagio brand to take some
steps into it and you know this is an
analogy we use all the time because
people often ask me oh who are some of
your web 2 Brands who are getting into
web3 and I say you know look at Johnny
Walker which has actually existed for
centuries and you know there's even like
a famous memorabilia of old Johnny
Walker ads that are in print right like
this is a brand that's kept walking
across centuries to connect with
consumers at various like cultural
moments of relevance can you talk a
little bit about the Journey of Johnny
Walker maybe starting from something
like gift code and up into uh the event
that Andre just mentioned uh at our
Basel yeah sure and and as you mentioned
Johnny Walker's one of our oldest most
storied Brands and I think that uh in
partnership with the brand team this
year we've done a good job of really
getting them into culture through web 3.
um and we wanted to do it in an
authentic way right because I think that
unfortunately the list of Brands is
pretty long that have gotten in for the
wrong reasons so web three or have
gotten in and Fallen flat and I think
that our approach really was test learn
and iterate as we've as we've launched
these different activations our first
step was to partner with the top 10 nft
collection to launch a limited edition
gift gift like bottle that we just gave
to those token holders so we're really
excited about that and then we moved
into on-chain activity where we
partnered with block bar which for those
of you that don't know you can block bar
works with Brands like us to Mint nfts
to pair with your physical products so
we actually launched a limited release
of Johnny Walker Blue Ghost and rare
which is a very special Johnny Walker
liquid and we paired that limited
release of bottles with nfts that
delivered a bundle of incremental value
for consumers right so we were able to
authenticate a hand signed bottle from
our Master distiller Emma Walker we were
able to deliver a storytelling
experience for those token holders uh
bought the nft to them with Emma and
then gave them you know first first shot
at our next drop on block bar as well as
an artwork nft that was uh designed and
developed by Ivonne Tao who's this
fantastic female artist in this space so
um really testing learning getting into
web 3 for the right reasons
authentically and um we're actually
really excited to to launch our latest
iteration of this at Art Basel where we
did another drop that was tied to a
physical bottle where you if you bought
the nft you actually got access to a VIP
event at Art Basel where you can taste
Johnny Walker Blue and actually interact
with an artist who's going to create
artwork uh they'll live on the bottle
when the bottle comes out in the future
so testing learning getting in and uh
experimenting is has been our approach
and I think we're gonna we're gonna do
that into 2023 as well
amazing I think this Echoes what just
was just saying right like having a few
sort of um agile plans that are built
upon themselves so it doesn't have to be
the biggest thing at once it can be um
continuing to connect with relevant
communities and grow and grow
um it sounds like that was a big part of
your strategy in this year so what are
we what can we look forward to for next
year with some of the Diageo Brands um
you know starting to uh continue
building into this world of web 3. yeah
look I think that
um one of the encouraging signs for me
is that there's they're starting to be
some Nuance in the public debate about
you know crypto nfts and utility
associated with those entities right so
one of the most encouraging things I saw
recently was Jamie Diamond was on CNBC
last week and obviously he has a very
firm view on crypto but he he did he
made a detailed call out that he was a
believer in web3 he was a believer in
blockchain and he was a believer in
smart contracts so for brand marketers
it's important that you know we listen
to the level of Education that continues
to rise and then to build on top of that
I think in 2023 the year ahead we're
going to continue to focus on you know
leveraging web 3 for our events
experiences you know amplifying our
Partnerships and culture like sports in
areas like sports
um because to me the most important
thing is the underlying technology that
we can use and the utility that that can
deliver to consumers so as education as
the education level about this space
Rises amongst our consumer base further
we're going to continue to get in we're
going to focus on those four those
spaces that I mentioned and the last one
I would say is is certainly loyalty
right consumer loyalty look at looking
how we uh leverage web 3 and the tech
not underlying technology to build
consumer loyalty for our brand portfolio
and some of our our digital platforms
it is going to be a very exciting year
for diagio and all of the incredible
brands that you all represent building
this space and I think you know Diageo
does so many cool experiential events I
think during our Basel alone there was
like at least a dozen tying um those
incredible experiential events with some
like digital loyalty component I think
is going to be really exciting to see so
I know our time here so thank you so
much for joining us Devin and sharing
your insights um and we'll hand it back
to Andrea thanks guys thanks for having
me thank you Devin and thanks every
Avery always a pleasure
all right we're next going to welcome up
Mark Evans who's the executive director
at the Sasha group Mark how are you
what's going on Andrea how are you oh
I'm excited about this next one I'm a
big carry fan we're going to bring up
Kerry Warren block
she is an amazing human she is the
founder and CEO of Earth kind a company
that keeps pests out without killing or
poisoning them it's an incredible
company with a big heart she also is an
author an inventor and an ey
entrepreneurial winning woman welcome
welcome welcome Carrie
so happy to be here what an incredible
introduction
Carrie Carrie I cannot believe we're
halfway through December 23 is right
around the corner it's our first year of
partnering together of earthcon and
Sasha I'm so stoked to be able to have
this combo with you because we've just
had a blast today but you know to build
on what Andrew is saying I'd love for
you to be able to give the viewers just
some more context on on Earth kind and
kind of why you started it and and what
you guys do so brilliantly sure happy
too well it actually all started when a
rodent ran out my bare leg kind of
freaked me out
um and then there was this continual
problems of rodents getting into our
farm equipment there really wasn't a
solution out there that was safe
effective kind to the environment safe
for my my kids and my pets so I
reimagined and basically reinvented the
way Pest Control could be done
um invented a little this is our first
product Tara little sachet pouch that
we've sold over 50 million of these to
reliably keep rodents out of enclosed
areas like nice push cars RVs what the
like and our products are sold across
major retailers all over the country and
yeah it's hard to believe that it all
started from just one little problem
like that
absolutely and I get I can testify my
garage is rodent free so thank you
um so I think we look back at this year
there's been a ton of growth for Earth
kind and it's come really from both kind
of from people the special people that
touch your brand both internally and
externally
um talk to me a bit about kind of like
how you think about your teams how do
you think about kind of finding the
right mix how do you create that Harmony
to be able to push the brand forward
it's just a smart way yeah absolutely
starting starting the brand really from
a shoestring and growing it into what it
is today I've really kept kept my focus
very simple you need a plan you need
alignment you need Stellar execution and
you need really good control so that's
the filter that I've used
um irregardless of the size we really
haven't had to change our our business
model
um but we have for instance seven
external teams that we work with and we
really consider them as an extension of
our own team so in many ways we treat
them like our own team
um and there's a lot of care and
generosity that goes into that
relationship which I believe that gets
the best from people but there is no
mistake for passion you can't fake it
um to me as far as return on investment
kindness does it as you know the name of
our company but looking for that in our
people and the Sasha team it's it's just
been a wonderful wonderful Journey this
year we took that bold step instead of
doing 100 things what are the two or
three things we really need to do this
year to nail it and I think in the
future we're going to continue to have
to think like that
got it and so you feel like the focus
was really an important thing this year
for the growth of earthcon Earth kind
in four skus and Walmart stores is
pretty important we do business with the
biggest retailers out there and they
still need people walking in their doors
um and and we need
um to have that really good connection
with the end user like we always have
from the beginning because we learn
every single day for instance when when
you look at what we did this year mark
with Tick Tock we opened our first Tick
Tock we did
um the Instagram reels the YouTube
shorts we got a pretty quick assessment
of what was really resonating with
people and we were able to quickly take
that in
um to our Lowe's account for instance
and see a lift by running ads from that
in a very authentic way to our brand
that was not salesy and um yeah we're so
pumped about that
yeah and I think that's and I think well
first of all I guess the love is always
felt when we work with Earth kind teams
that's always fun for us but I think
when we think about the content that
we've created together you know it's
been a mixture of being able to bring to
life you and all the great stories and
the passion that you bring and being
able to capture that and be able to
deliver that in content but also being
able just I think you know humanize uh
you know rodents or be able to just like
bring to life little quick facts and
tidbits that I think people really you
know appreciate and enjoy and they're
kind of everyday like did you know you
know life
yeah you know when we started 98 of
everything sold to control a pest was
poison it was kill it was inhumane and
really we we've since the very beginning
we've been looking at people that want
to join hands with us and go on this
journey with us and really change the
way
um Pest Control is done and perceived
um and really the only way to do that is
to touch their heart and to give them
something in their mind right here's the
facts and here's why uh this should
matter to you and is important
um so getting that mix right was was
really important for us especially on
social which is Sasha runs all her
social you get to check it out and see
what we're doing but um I'm really happy
that we got the mix right
absolutely absolutely
um one of my favorite quotes from Gary
is you know a brand will outsell any
salesman and I think about your brand
your brand is so powerful and so near
and dear to your heart as you continue
to expand and get bigger like how do you
stay true to that kind of initial brand
vision
yeah
that's funny if you ask our partners and
employees of people that know me I've
been you know really a stickler ever
since the beginning that you absolutely
have to care every time we walk into a
merchant room or any relationship I want
people to leave saying this was worth
our time this was not a waste of time
whether that's the customer
um whether that's anybody that works in
our company
um it's just so so very important and
those insights genuinely come from our
people when when their hearts are open
and they're not scared to tell you what
they think or what they see or what's
going on and I always think it's better
to have 10 000 people like brand
Advocates looking right and watching for
you rather than having one person
sitting at a desk making a decision
that's when things that's when things
really go sideways so unfortunately we
have that with with our teams I'm
grateful and honored absolutely and I
always think I I love how you look at
you know the the digital Community is
like really building a community and the
importance of having people really
embrace the brand understand the brand
and really be able to connect with them
and I think so many times Brands don't
look at that that way it's like you're
like no let's build a community and I
think I just love that kind of mindset
it's oh my gosh it's so valuable so so
valuable especially when you live from
North Dakota which is where I started
the company it's not like we could get
out so we were in we've been in the
cloud for a long long time and I heard
Gary speak in 2007 or eight and I
instantly went home and I saw the value
in in this and started to put down it
was like we got all the accounts and
started our journey of communicating
with customers in a very authentic way
and it's been the key to our growth we
really haven't even had an in internal
sales leader
because of that our customers have been
driving it for us which is awesome
excellent excellent I know we have a
only a few seconds left but anything
that's exciting you about 23.
should we pretty much hit our goals this
year we're making our bigger goals I'd
love for people to sign up for our
newsletter follow us follow our
community see what we're doing
um that's going to be something really
exciting for us we'll put the link
um and in um my social channels here
thanks for having me on today
absolutely absolutely thank you for
taking the time Carrie
thank you Carrie and thank you Mark
happy holidays
all right oh there she is our chief
heart officer Claude
so good to have you here yeah great to
be here oh my goodness and you're gonna
bring us home excited about this uh this
last interview of 2022. we're gonna have
Sarah Rodell who is the CEO and founder
of Loop and Ty she's going to tell you
all about the business but I'm
personally just thrilled by our
partnership uh we just engaged on world
kindness day
um and giving some gifts with heart a
personalized gifting program we love the
heartbeat in your organization because
it matches ours so very excited about
the conversation and I'll hand it over
to YouTube
thanks Andrea hi Sarah great to see you
again so happy to be here great I was
wondering if you could just tell us a
little bit about you I know you came
from finance and now you're in the world
of giving and giving with heart who are
you what are you all about and what is
loop and tie yes yes
um you know Lupine Thai is very much an
expression of the things that I care
about in the world which is being able
to
um connect with and show gratitude to
more people in a super personalized way
so I built the company because I was
really interested in how we could take
the billions of dollars that are being
spent by companies in their recognition
and rewards programs and use that to
support small businesses and causes an
underrepresented Founders through what
we call collection-based Commerce
um so our idea is to kind of change the
game in the way gifting is done so
instead of picking a single item you
send a collection of choices and people
can choose what they want and with that
choice comes the ability to surface just
more Niche offerings and we can Surface
stories and let people pick a gift that
really connects with who they are
amazing so can do you mind going back a
little bit to how this even became a
purpose for you sure
um so I really experienced uh the
problem firsthand of volunteering to
send gifts to a lot of people and found
that it was more of a formality than it
was actually useful to them and and that
was interesting to me because I feel
like that's a dropped ball right any
opportunity can to connect can be really
meaningful and can have a lot of
positive Ripples and I felt like if we
changed the way that companies can
connect with their customers we have
this opportunity to support sort of a
wider range of of people I mean you
remind me in in even in speaking to
prior to this call reminds me so much of
the Maya Angelou quote that we we say a
lot which is people forget what you said
people forget what you did but people
will never forget how you made them feel
it's a huge huge thing for me and it
really sounds like the connection point
for you in terms of just the human and
the heart and the act of giving rather
than
you know sending something out kind of
cheap and cheerful because you kind of
have to right right and I think
um we're you know at the beginning of
when I was building this company if I
talked about um the role of gratitude in
the corporate environment I was looked
at like some crazy hippie
um that's changed which is you know a
wonderful uh Evolution I would say of
the broader market and um and just the
broader tone but one of the things that
I think is really incredible when
gifting does become a part of your
business practice is this transition
away from treating people in this
transactional way into something that
feels more inclusive and Invitational
and so something that I think the gift
can do when it's not a formality is
really build a bridge of understanding
who a person is so you sort of move out
of this often tiring Dynamic of just
transacting with somebody else we're not
really designed for that kind of
um feeling uh in perpetuity it's it's
sort of exhausting but all of a sudden
we're enlivened when and you get to know
somebody who you might be you know
wanting to sell something to you might
be wanting to hire in a much more human
way and I think that you guys have
always embodied that that's been a
really
um core part of the way that that you
know vayner's been built and I remember
uh watching the thank you economy talk
that Gary did right when I was starting
the company and that you know the the
tenants sort of within that on how to
build community
um and and bring the humanness into the
the commercial space
um have always been just really powerful
motivators for me yeah and actually even
jab jab jab right hook if you think of
the ethos around that which is give give
give
and then ask you know we get I get asked
24 7 like what is the ROI of kindness
what is the ROI of bringing heart into
the workplace and I usually say like
what isn't the ROI really what isn't
yeah so I'm gonna ask you the question
just because it gets asked to me yeah
what is the ROI of giving with heart
what does the ROI of Invitational giving
which we're going to get into a sec
um the way I approach that question it
it um it makes me actually think of one
of my favorite metaphors
um which has to do with with farming
systems so uh so here we are
um you know one of the the things that I
uh take the most uh inspiration from is
the way natural systems work so if you
look at an industrial Farm um it's all
about increasing yield when you do that
after five or so years you don't have
the nutrition you need in the soil so
you've got to move somewhere else right
if you look at more regenerative or
biodynamic farming practices it's about
taking really good care of the soil and
when you do that really good food
happens to come and so to me the ROI is
thinking you know getting out of this
myopic space where you're trying to say
when I give one gift I get five more
customers that's not the kind of
mentality I think that's going to create
long-term sustainability and that's more
of this industrial mindset but if we
zoom out and say okay if we're investing
in this soil of our relationships the
way we connect who our brand is how we
show up in the world really good food is
going to happen to come right our brand
is going to be sustaining we're going to
attract the kind of employees and the
kind of customers that stay with us for
the Long Haul
I love that by the way you kind of give
a nod to Carrie who is just on hard talk
I love when you're talking really you're
talking about just like
being more human in this in the space
that she's in it's such a dichotomy
because we're in a world in which things
are transactional social so I get a like
you like my content you gotta like you
gotta get a like and so what you're what
you're doing is really helping us I
would say unlearn this idea and can we
talk about you know unlearning a little
bit or relearning how to
give how to be generous yes yes
um well you know I uh I think that that
is such a a deep question like there's
so many things we need to unlearn
um one of the biggest things that I
think um we are open to unlearning at in
sort of the macro environment right now
is stress as a motivator I think stress
is a really powerful short-term
motivator
um long-term motivators are things like
creativity safety appreciation and so
when we think about the activities that
engender that kind of environment you
know gifting is a part of it but it's
really broadly this recognition
um mindset that I think is super
important and um and you know one of the
things that I love to just sort of
punctuate that is our bodies show us
that if you're under continual stress
you get sick you cannot create if you
are appreciated if you are given space
um where you feel like you can try new
things
um you do grow and so I think any
activity that supports that is something
that we need to double down on and
there's a lot collectively that we need
to unlearn around the stories with
stress and pressure and you know you've
got to work hard and sort of break your
back in order to achieve anything
um it's sort of right-sizing our
relationship with those things yeah I
love what you say it's really you know
we are in this pivotal moment right now
where so many paradigms have the
opportunity to change including this one
and can you talk us through uh you know
you talk a lot about Invitational giving
and one of the things you and I chatted
about was okay there's intention yep and
then there's invitation can we just talk
about the the uh discrepancies there the
differences because they're subtle yeah
it's super subtle and I think to me
um invitation is it's an action right
it's something it's it's intention
manifest out into the world and I love
talking about this concept of more
Invitational Commerce more educational
company building because what it really
speaks to is creating something that
you're proud of and you're saying hey
here I am come hang out with me or not
you know your decision versus something
that is more transactional or extractive
which is positioning manipulating trying
to get something out of you and it's
sort of a Tit for Tat and that is to me
just not something that's sustainable
and so as I look forward
um into 2023 I do I also feel like we're
kind of you know exhausted like we went
from pandemic to recession our nervous
systems are like I just need a nap you
know and I think that that kind of uh
Dynamic creates that's the rupture that
you need for growth and for Change and
so
um I love talking about
um you know how to instill more
Invitational practices into the way you
connect with your customers the way you
connect with your employees because I
think it gives us that opportunity to
really be more heart centered be more
authentic and kind of see what what
comes in when you are just putting that
out in the world
so it sounds like you would say for 23
it's it's more Humanity for the win yeah
listening becoming more mindful not
using stress as a motivator yes you're
as a motivator but really
taking
intentional but Invitational
proactivity exactly exactly you know and
I I'd say
um a big theme that we've been talking
about is values oriented uh commercial
activities like just to be as broad as
possible being Center Stage
um and and what that looks like to me is
being able to kind of dial back and say
okay who are we again like how do we get
out of react mode you know and how do we
communicate that because I I think that
um you know again a question that I've
gotten a lot that I find really
interesting is
um people are wanting to know how do you
connect how do you give in this economic
environment they're not talking about
their budgets they're talking about the
tone right they're wanting to understand
how do I connect in this like space
where there's a lot of triggers out
there and and so I think um that type of
macro environment is inviting in the
space of where you know the question
we're asking Brands back when we get
this is what are your values what are
your trying to communicate onto the
world are you do you really care about
sustainability do you really care about
inclusivity like how can we put that
front and center and consider the way
that you communicate that on a broader
scale
I love it I love it we could go on and
on and on well thank you so much and
thank you for partnering with us for uh
for Gary's birthday World kindness day
and happy holidays to you thank you so
much for having me happy holidays
thanks to you both for closing us out
that was fantastic lots of love lots of
heart going on
all right well thank you everyone for
joining our session today and we're
looking forward to seeing you in the new
year we'll have our next episode of
marketing for the now in January but not
until January 30th
um where we're going to talk about some
pretty cool hot takes for 2023 we'll be
back from CES and have all kinds of
interesting things so uh thanks to all
of you for your support this past year
and we're looking forward to seeing you
very very soon happy holidays everybody
and